here's that random for you I was
thinking another random four that are in
the random facts now thought about when
I was high okay
so music music no one I I don't know how
music originated brah brah but there was
someone out there that thought music
should go verse chorus verse chorus
bridge chorus who invented a chorus
first then form it does that make sense
yes and then when you hear a song that
is all verse no chorus you think I'll
[ __ ] that song another chorus that's a
haiku fam there's not song yeah oh it
tree it's not [ __ ] soul but you get
one common form and someone actually for
you should go first chorus verse chorus
bridge chorus but why
and then someone for like one minute is
more of an institute it's not that long
enough but seven minutes you get a bit
bored so we'd say about 3 to 4 minutes
would be a song yeah mic like EPS and
albums as well hmm when it like asks for
songs EP scene EP 17 songs 17 songs
there's an album album but then if you
want to be a [ __ ] if you want to be
ways if you want to be like a Kanye West
and do it I'm gonna do a three song
album and you've called it cause the
ruckus yeah what's the [ __ ]
difference yes there is no difference
there's a title different it's songs on
a CD or like on whatever on social
wherever you meant to be on so there is
actually a very the difference between
an EPIRB is this and this is why is this
and this is why you do shut up whoever
says that you're bored you're bored
there's always someone who's gonna
[ __ ] say it you're bored everyone I
didn't say because I wanted an answer I
just want to rant I hate you know what I
hate
I [ __ ] hate sometimes you know when
you you know sometimes we just wanna run
yeah you just want to run and get it out
yeah yeah if someone comes with the
logical rebuttal
that's my [ __ ] brother all the time
every time you wonder like what's the
[ __ ] deal with this yeah and you ran
in him like oh yeah because the economy
on [ __ ] Japan doesn't allow for
retrospective [ __ ] and you're just
like shut ur so boring shut up let me
run you're so boring
I didn't speak so you could put me in my
place I'm not arguing with ya you're my
friend and I'm one in the ear you're my
friend and I'm wonder why you put me in
my place
ah that's hilarious that's confrontation
that's a I said something you rebuttal
do something else that's hilarious
confrontation you know [ __ ] it I
actually hate you know that hates you
like that sometimes just listen to them
it's a thing as well it's like um
obviously alright guys enjoy I reckon
all the time I love Joe Rogan he does
this one thing that gets my [ __ ] tits
mmm and sometimes I'll have a guest or a
veteran on someone and they'll be 10
like a story mmm you'd be like ah bro
you know what I heard that like it's
just a story in it it's just a joke
stories I heard about this house I was
on tour and I had to stay at this house
and they put me up in this room and what
you call it to put me up in this [ __ ]
room and then I spoke to my boy and he
said that like 19 man were just busting
nuts in there was some gay orgy and
hanging like that
and he's trying to tell this story to
Joe and Dover like oh you mean the house
on such-and-such knee but yeah yeah yeah
the story's not true is actually this
and you know oh why are you ruining my
store let me tell the story
oh god just let me tell the story he's
ruined the whole clan sir the truth yeah
ruining Ruben and fun the facts it does
the facts don't matter really never fun
with that it's so easy to ruin fun with
fact I like that I didn't care if it was
real or not that's not the point of the
story yeah yeah you can't help but say
yeah that's not true yeah oh I don't
think that's true yeah so what let me
run my mouth and it's love that's what I
came here to do is why these cameras
have run I wanted to run them up enough
and you ruined it from the facts do you
know what I'm so funny cuz fun with
facts
sounds like fun with flags I did you
know my father with flags is from from
Big Bang Theory shell did a Navy and you
ever watch Big O 3 rarely I don't watch
TV fun oh yeah I don't like to [ __ ]
arm it just remind me of that so much I
don't know why fun with facts fun with
flags anyway that's that's not even all
there
what I want to hit you with she remember
hot damn I rock okay King Carter he was
if you've never seen him
YouTube him he was way ahead of his time
like in terms of the stuff he sketch is
everything and the one one sketch later
did that always resonated to me was that
he said he was at home he was texting a
chick or whatever and he was horny as
[ __ ] horny as [ __ ] but she lived X Y Z
and he was like should I go and [ __ ]
this girl read her
he said he's mind was saying no but he's
hard dick was saying yes he's like hard
dick can make you do stupid things
stupid things like hard dick is is the
actual devil because you would actually
do you will go above and beyond to get
please what to release that urge and
past that not borrowed there was
specific example mmm there's a girl I
was talking to I used to work this was
years ago yeah it's the work of her she
random she randomly start messaging me
I've nowhere I think she she left the
company random you start missing me I
know her I was in bed I remember one day
I got in bed yeah um
bridges asleep it was stab it and I know
I had the day off the next day off but I
remember I'm ready to sleep yeah she's
messaging me and she's like come through
yeah she lived in Bedford which is like
45min oh like 40 minutes yeah from mine
so I was like I'm gonna get out the car
I'm gonna get our bed yeah
get dressed and probably brush my
[ __ ] teeth or something
go there drive all the way there at
[ __ ] o'clock in the hope that she's
not [ __ ] me about because like we
don't work together anymore
we're never gonna see each other she
could have just been [ __ ] me with
malarkey to be fair she came in her
address she probably wouldn't be [ __ ]
around but anyway yeah you never know -
yeah all the way yeah just a [ __ ] yeah
and then maybe I'll stay there may be a
warning I'll come home all the way again
and buy her but he's gotta be 4 a.m.
before we know it fam my mind said no my
hard dick said yes hundred percent was
one solution bout I told myself
I'm gonna have a wank if I still want to
go if I still want to go after that's
just one out no go bashed slap fun
happens every week I make it week in
week out ash and clams the amount of
times I'm horny in bed just horny alone
and just in bed I'm thinking you're
texting every yacht under decided
everybody out on your own you're [ __ ]
glossary you're texting them all hmm
when am I seeing you Rhetta tear disdain
you ever we need to do dis some of the
replies some of them don't but the point
is still loaded and you're still trying
to bash your like your dela oh yeah I
can't wait to [ __ ] you I call me bro
most crud mmm as soon as I bust that nut
my phone is on the floor I don't give a
like I don't kept you can reply me I'm
not anymore
there have been specific times in my
life where I've had porn ready to go hmm
it's just a quick bite there's no
occasion there's just a bash before I go
to sleep or something hmm
I've had porn ready to go is that direct
to you was that story no this is a story
but she sent me something
it was a fun this is the thing that sent
you that had that you forty was she a
Denis forties oh yes I thought that
Jesus I'm sort of just just for the
cameras sake
there was a girl tinder tinder her tits
were so big I thought she was sitting
like this
these were it is now I thought was her
knees rather I never sat it's anyway
there's been specific times in my life
where [ __ ] was I saying
there's been specific time but there's
been specific times in my life where I'm
actually having like sex chat messaging
girl
sex chat yeah she's horny i'm horny it's
a situation we're probably not gonna
[ __ ] that night I'm somewhere ready and
I've had to delay watching the porn
because I know where we are in the chat
that if i watch the porn
bash bust it's not I'm not carrying okay
I'm going to sleep rugs I'm just getting
on with it my day rags
I'm not consuming me the sexual talk
rags it's crazy like I need to know as
well for guys because obviously with a
guy hmm as soon as you boss mmm it's how
do I is undescribable so like anything
else he's indescribable is literally
like it stops yeah it complete yeah and
a few moments came causing your brain
work that quickly don't make sense don't
make everything you couldn't pay me to
[ __ ] in one after I've just bust that
second 100 percent after just like
literally just bus if someone said I'll
give you a million quid for this guy but
no no it's impossible no the last thing
I want to do I'm gonna sleep I want you
to [ __ ] off I don't want to sleep but I
don't want to be touched
how do we've spoken to I just want to be
left alone what's worse is when you
busting up with a chick that you know
you don't want to cuddle or you know
that you don't want them stare your yeah
worse not you know what does I just do
what those are the worst not ever like
obviously let's say your girlfriend just
you're actively dating someone and you
[ __ ] a boss and I you took like I'm
call me that cuz you can talk universe
what I'm happy with that but actual
slags or whatever that you just [ __ ]
like you bust this now you know
I've got a she's ever got a go or I've
gotten I mean less which if let's say
it's at my heart for example like if she
has to sleep here
I'm vex cuz it's like [ __ ] of what I've
actually got to entertain her now
obviously was all fun and games when she
stepped through the door like we start
blood all that [ __ ] but now she's gonna
know she's gotta stay as long it's long
that is
I think I saw on Tibet or something hard
dick no post nut clarity makes you know
whether you're like a god or not ah one
because the amount of horrid I can speak
crust to any go in this earth just the
boss or not as soon as the bus or not
that would determine whether I like you
or not so for me if [ __ ] for guys is
trial and error I don't know if I like
you dude I mean I actually don't know if
I like you yeah may just like you enough
to bust this not and once that bus is
not do I actually like you because I
know it's like yeah exactly I know it's
like and I know whoever said that's the
difference we knew who my girlfriend oh
you're just someone facts there's like
um but what was it gonna say as well I
want to know how it is for females cuz
after they know they can go again
they can again so that's like a reset
and then go again or can they just no
girls you go obvious got some cover get
once they like squirt they can go again
and I don't get I know I know it's true
because always if I'm nine times out of
ten hmm I will eat [ __ ] hmm until she
nuts mmm and then and then bucket yeah
usually after if she's not it she's
gagging - [ __ ] yeah I'm thinking if you
sucked me off until ice boss and then
you you are going to be disappointed
because I'm getting flaccid and I'm
going to bed
yeah word of wisdom girls need to
establish a difference between this is a
come [ __ ] and this is a foreplay
[ __ ] 100 percent because sometimes
there's there's a thin line I can tell
there's nothing impress in it so they're
giving you a calm [ __ ] but they don't
realize once I not come blow jobs are
hard to find as well if you can perform
a very good combo job I'm sorry I don't
want have sex anymore
Oh
this is a this is it this is the needle
in a haystack this is the pen we found
it this is the Champions League like
this is the goal yeah so I don't even
you don't have a vagina anymore you
don't exist like the throat yeah you've
got that neck and this is how this party
ends and I'm sorry is your own fault
it's actually your business but if you
want me to knight in your throat then
that's fine that's fine be fine but if
you're doing it because you want to
create an ambience create a different
[ __ ] you need a full plate [ __ ]
there has to be a distinctive difference
between the two I think I do you need to
turn you down a little bit yeah that's
all she brought I'm high yeah that's
cotton that's gone it's gone yeah bro
yeah literally because it ruins the font
for everyone I don't want to have to do
that to you mmm I don't want to have to
because I know like obviously later or
tomorrow I'm gonna regret yeah we
shoulda just had a good time and we
should have done whatever but at the
time I can't see just like you said on
the hot damn Eric team hard dick is
important even has his own mind in his
own motivations Oh facts and women need
to work around that mmm cuz I'm not in
control anymore
mmm I'm not in control anymore mmm it's
crazy it's crazy it's like when um
have you ever seen where have you seen
what kind of Beast a woman turns into
when you give her the dip and then in
and out that quick bang bang yeah and
she'll say no no no no no I don't wanna
[ __ ] die one fight until you give me
the one one dip the I rock it takes her
soul away but she'll scratch your eyes
out if you know [ __ ] just scratch your
[ __ ] eyeballs out it's scary
is no I know I know that's what hard
dick before before you put a dick in if
there's it like not knowin like a rape
thing no but like it's just [ __ ] about
you barely doable I mean you're [ __ ]
out there why did you invite me over
[Music]
give that one
that one game over different beasts I
did or beast Oh Moll you think you
better know should we let that and
that's another thing that's another
thing obviously we spoke about this
yesterday already yeah there are times
in which you have good days and bad days
some days for some reason who takes
extra sensitive and you just got a bus
early do is pull out reset take a breath
hmm
and then get your head straight and then
go again we can have a great time yeah
but they don't want that they don't want
that because if you pull out they turn
into that ting describe eyeball ting and
is gay but but they don't realize I'm
its 1.7 pumps away from ruining
everyone's day 3 pump Pete like brass
it's mud because 9 times that attend
that that initial ting is more time
missionary and for me a so it's a
weakness for me weakness for especially
as [ __ ] especially when I know that
freaky if I slide no no even freaking
when is wet like gosh where when it's
gosh wet oh my god oh my god because I
can I can busting up in about 30 seconds
if I wanted to and I said it's you
earlier I'll be [ __ ] a chicken
missionary then should be making sounds
like that drives me insane that drives
that like psychologically it does
something to me it turns me into a
[ __ ] animal there's certain phrases
and I just don't care about the
longevity of the beam I just want to not
because it's you convince yourself that
you can convince it doesn't even matter
if I bust because I'm gonna be ready to
go big in about four seconds flat this
is the best [ __ ] ever bad yeah I'm
gonna be so ready
soon the chemical imbalance I need to I
need to sort of a specialist the
chemical imbalance as soon as you
ejaculate oh my god sex is the the
least possible thing is literally like
being like I've never been so hot in my
life like I'm your boiling hot never
been so hot in my life like I've never
been so [ __ ] hot and then someone -
is like an ice bucket on you and they
say are you HOT you want to punch me
stupid yeah obviously I'm not [ __ ]
hot but you said you were hot
yeah until I got I stepped on me so
you're not hot you're not no that's bad
that's but I'm not but you said you
wanted to [ __ ] yes
but I'm done I don't wanna forget
anymore that doesn't make sense ten
seconds ago you went to follow my good
right doesn't make any sense
oh my god so let's talk about top five
mailed insecurities top five male
insecurity so I've figured out a list
Wow top five an excuse and this goes for
anyone okay creed color hi race
everything and I feel like it's it's
valid so top five are not it not in any
particular order height mm-hmm
hairline wait for it we'll discuss
everything right hairline sex game slash
dick size financial status and your body
type like your physique those are ladies
that's a man's top five in script no
matter what they say everything they
will tell you falls into those
categories anything they'll tell you
that they insecure about will fall into
those categories and that's a hundred
percent recon hundred percent shoe calm
so that's not with height height why is
it interesting one heist is interesting
cuz we've been speaking about hype
non-stop really high is interesting
because like I don't know like it not
necessarily you have a full five by the
way you won't have all fives yeah yeah
yeah obviously they are they will always
fall you always have at least one of
them yeah probably these two but like
height Heights I've gone back and forth
of an height because like I'm cool with
my height I'm five-eleven
Pham speaking off they're looking at
twenty school there's six hour podcast
and just on those five topics a broth
right when I was on tinder
there's a [ __ ] guy Tundra does have
you seen a white guy in America the
[ __ ] guy and he was kicking off in
like a [ __ ] chick-fil-a yes yes yes
yes I get off about his height and stuff
when I will never forget when I was on
tinder mmm if you're under six foot
we'll never be more than friends wife
left swipe left if you're under how dare
you want you how dare you if I can
actually if you're not double D's don't
message me fam that's what I want to put
if your ass ain't fat don't message
delete the app if you're fat [ __ ] off
but you would never get guys saying that
you'll be have you'll get hate me chaos
but that high stuff they love they love
to pluck a nerve they just love the
thing is as well as like when you
compare your height actually looking at
another dude it's like such a minor
insecurity like if you've got taller
friends and stuff like that it's not
quant it's not the forefront of your
mind - this [ __ ] guy's making it up
short you don't really care that much
it's the women that implant that
insecurities of course 100% I just want
to like this and that and that but the
thing is as well what I find about women
and I find it definitely relates to
height in that you find so many women
that obviously is only select few hot
tall guys yeah but for example if you
got dude who loves big tits
his girlfriend's having big tits
understand if you ain't got big tits
you're not gonna be his girlfriend under
because he loves bigger he could [ __ ]
you yeah you know give his girlfriend Oh
women will love height suppose it Lea
but their boyfriend will be sure or not
sure but he's not going to be tall and I
often find that a lot of women's tastes
I don't I'm I might be completely wrong
hmm and I get a lot of stick for it but
a lot of women's tastes are implanted
tastes mmm they're not necessarily
they're genuinely opinions yeah yeah
it's just like that's the general
consensus and have been looking for a
tall guy yeah is just what you look for
yeah
so whether they actually give a [ __ ] if
he's tall or not is it is a completely
irrelevant issue its I have a type
yeah tall like you ask girl what's your
type toes tall yeah yeah yeah just study
did she even think about it did she just
say talk yeah and I have never been
concerned about my height until I've
heard women talk about height
and yeah that's actually true and give
us the ping and like but they don't
necessarily go only go for tall guys
yeah and I'm completely out of the park
but they'll happily tell me what someone
is toward this is this and this and this
and like the tinder thing just ruin my
life and then they're just like ah when
[ __ ] would ask me on tinder how old
are you how dare you what is it mom how
dare you how tall are you
and then we left for 9 doesn't I know I
know
it doesn't matter doesn't matter it
doesn't and then just like five five
eleven is not sure from and I'm gonna
get so many comments like yes it is yes
it [ __ ] is do you want to laugh I
have anything you're sure yeah
so you know you've seen the meme unlike
there's a difference between a woman
that's five nine and a guy that's fine
let me tell you a story so does the
chick that Fox before I always claimed
five nine I'd actually don't know how
tall am I think I'm like five eight in a
bit by always claimed five nine so she
came mind we're talking Rhetta this was
awesome like generic questions blah blah
she's like oh by the way how tall are
you I was like oh I'm five nine and she
just looked at me no he's in person this
it face to face face to face and as as
soon as she made that face was like yeah
probably bout five minute because the
reason why she did that is because she's
five nine and there's a different you
know I mean there's a there's a
difference in high and it's like from
women knew a five nine are six seven
100% is this something to do with a body
like way doesn't make sense like your
five nut but you can look six one bro
I've seen women that five nine that are
six one it makes no sense he was
excluded no sense it's funny funny I
told you the story the first time I met
V Tom
first time I met V tom was the first
time I've ever been insecure about my
height cuz she's she's like five eight
five nine mmm and she's [ __ ] tall but
like the first time we met and picked up
God must been ten ten years ago
something
now no--yeah brought about eight seven
eight years ago she picked me up in a
whip hmm so I was in the flat yeah
she said I'm downstairs never met before
she's in their car we're gonna go grab a
McDonald's or something because I'm cool
got in the car how are you decision on
catfish
cetera cetera okay I go to get
McDonald's I step out of the car onto
the curb she sits out of her side of the
car into the street from where I was
standing we were the same height
um fear no actually no I was a little
bit taller on the curb I didn't realize
I was on the curb and I looked and I was
like but didn't bother me because I
thought I'm still like solidly taller
than yeah yeah and then I stepped down
and literally as soon as you saw my chin
just I felt like we were eye to eye like
nose to nose I was like oh no and it
didn't jump to my head the dread this is
the big thing about it as well this is
why women are [ __ ] women would look at
that situation and be like yuck you're
sure yeah they won't be like Fox ankle
why am i taller than all these guys yeah
like should we look at me and be like oh
you're sure that's a shame like it's
your fault yeah that's a shame
yeah that's a shame there's nothing I do
where there's a guy looking at me I
wasn't like oh she's told yuck I was
like I'm sure we're too generous is
nothing to do by because I didn't think
oh you're tall I fought [ __ ] I'm sure
yeah fam I'm not gonna light for the
rest of the day I would try my tiptoes
whenever she didn't know I was walking
or standing or if there was something
covering my feet I was on my tips
elevated so embarrassed that's hilarious
so embarrassed eight one gate one dozen
laughter that go over it but that's
hilarious bro
it's just height it's a serious insecure
there was one time was out I've never
really been insecure about our height
there was one time we're out you came to
Northampton
yeah years ago and we were somewhere I
think like revs or somewhere like that
just bar it wasn't like out and we were
standard by the bar and my fountain
Saints rugby team were out as a team
every male in there played for the
Saints probably don't remember we went
to the bar yeah and it was a busy bar so
say you got a long bar yeah we had
Saints players us slaves and I looked
around and it was literally like did it
zing up did it a bit never so
embarrassed really never been so we look
like [ __ ] kids we look [ __ ] kids
no one's baguette positon I know clearly
obviously and I was like we're sure but
then next level talk yeah they're
talking that I don't want to be that
tall but yeah it's a weird insecurity
this but yeah that wasn't you hit the
nail on the head with that one I told
you that's that's number one hairline
but the Fox no let me get this straight
I give all the Fox I give all of the Fox
so many so many I love the way you
change your phone I give every possible
[ __ ] thumb but I feel like I'm fine I
know what you mean
so it doesn't isn't it's never bothered
me know what you mean but my brother
went to Bob is the other day this is the
thing this is the thing that you never
know you're insecure about it and it
doesn't gradually increase it goes from
zero to 100 yeah brother most where Bob
is the other day and then obviously get
it line up yeah and then he's getting a
little bit on the sides in it yeah and
then the bubble was like cold you want
me to not spray thing Phyllis in and he
was like use I'd want me to and he was
like way to what he's you know he was
like why would I want you to do that
yeah he was like from then on I was no
no he came home and told oh [ __ ] about
it and I was just like prov from then on
he's just gonna be insecure about his
hairline no that's it that is it because
for me as well when my hair grows in
terms of my having to trim my hairline
isn't normally straight like if it wants
have been I've got like I've got a bit
hair dye always grows like always a
triangle take that triangle tear manic
like that it drives me insane I don't
blame you drives me the [ __ ] insane so
I'm a hair my hairline is starting to go
up here and it has been for time but
sometimes you can notice in your car
it's only when we never got a trim it's
not like the forefront of what you're
looking at but when I don't have a trim
you can kind of tell I do not mean so
hell for me Helen to his point like
every time I look in the mirror I'm
thinking shinies get a trim Jenny's
going but when I say to someone I knees
got hair you can't tell me my hair's
fine because you don't know why I have
to go I mean you don't know why I have
to look every day because I know what's
best for me and you know what's best for
you so don't tell me I don't need a trim
don't give me your top pants when
everyone has asked for oh my god bro I
know that you know I mean like it's not
it's none of your business I'm just
expressing myself I didn't ask for
feedback I didn't ask for comments to
let you know I need to get be brewing in
pharma facts I didn't ask for your
opinion I just wanted to run that is too
funny yeah it's one of those things that
when do you when if ever I don't know
but like once it starts peeling back mmm
when do you just say accepted I've
accepted it and either accept it and
don't think about it anymore you just
carry on and it just makes his way or do
you jump the gun skin and just [ __ ]
skin it like Toby but he pulled it the
[ __ ] off I don't think Toby was balding
at all I think he just changed his style
because he's always he ever had like
that high twist top we had alone it was
even late was I can even peel though so
it was like the whole line was just is
it my than that but yeah he pulled it
the [ __ ] off his bone look his buff like
I look like a [ __ ] idiot bro I'd look
like a [ __ ] you need like a melon a
black melon I never seen one of those no
because no I have a what the [ __ ] is
that exactly
that's what this would be briar look
like a [ __ ] idiot
in my head I look like one of those guys
from a Kevin Hart movie the
light-skinned like common or the other
guy from CSI I know exactly
in my head like what a 10-man exactly I
know my [ __ ] wooden comment
that's so funny
light-skinned dudes that pull it off
yeah and they look better like that but
they're head shapes perfect mm-hmm they
haven't got a head shape it's just it's
just you know a minute it's just as
exactly it's just a cylinder mmm
mine isn't like that I might as well -
yeah prophethood in I'll have to win
really pissing enough yeah now I'm
getting to our age though where like I'm
starting to look at like my dad and like
males in my family that is like pre in
their hair like my dad the thing with my
pops ever since I was young I've never
seen my dad with a head full of hair
he's always shave down here and it's
always quite a bit like my dad the only
facial hair my dad's face is his
eyebrows and eyelashes he's skin way
suits him because I've never seen him
any other way so when I see him in old
pictures with like heaven like a Kinect
and being a mustache thing you know
[ __ ] weird there you know I mean yeah
so I could potentially skin it and look
normal but it would have to just get
used to it because I know my dad didn't
know his baldness my dad I've seen
pictures in my deck on my udders so some
old pigeons II had like a flattop and
[ __ ] raaah but I see his hairline now
and his hair lines peel back a little
bit but if he grew it he'd have a full
head of hair it just have a bit of
receding hairline he's in his mid-50s so
that gives me a local piece of
confidence on my mum's side every guy
all my mom's brothers I'm like that
mom's dad is that they weren't bought in
their 20s 20s board completely born in
their 20s it gives me anxiety last wild
twenties is wild bro it's [ __ ] [ __ ]
so that worries me a little bit mmm but
yeah as a whole hair line is a is a big
deal because it's nothing you [ __ ] do
about it there is a really and then once
you start doing something to buy it you
have to keep going let's give you decide
like I can't buff to keep doing this
anymore
yeah and then go into work on Wednesday
and you're just like who the [ __ ] is
that
yeah yeah I know what you mean so yeah
what wasn't it got high covered we've
got a hairline covered
so dick sex game again G slash just
alright we've all the same ballpark same
ballpark because you can't really do
much about your dick size but like your
sex games as well so that's all in the
same same ballpark
yeah you spoke about a lot today yeah
like so as I said already like you have
good days and bad days everyone does and
that's fine never for women now which is
weird because but that's the thing and
then like I think sometimes women don't
realize how much pressure there is to
perform and we said like it there's only
one time to make a first impression
yes and it's so standard that you know
for a [ __ ] fat that if you give a
girl [ __ ] dick the next day the group
that's blowing up your bridges our
worker blowing up yeah like everyone
knows that you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] scrub
like you're nothing under your [ __ ] [ __ ]
understand it's just like let me have
another chance and even if you do get no
it's like this unless you unless your
wife err yeah and then that can get
brushed on yeah yeah yeah you're always
gonna be known as guy that gave you [ __ ]
dick yeah you're gonna be like just the
[ __ ] dick guy saved in the phone it's
like when I'm bored I like the [ __ ] dick
good until someone better comes on man
and then she's partying yes a wrap but
that hat could be no reflection on your
day-to-day like I've had times good few
times where yeah man I just have a [ __ ]
day two pumps bang and I'm like [ __ ] and
you know you're never gonna [ __ ] that
girl yeah yeah and you just like I know
shortage [ __ ] Shoreditch [ __ ] but I
actually don't remember a name but a
class or a short to describe me on my
way to shortage and it just Ryan the
shortage [ __ ] FATA sauce I've ever seen
in my entire life got a number on that
day matter to two weeks later went away
yard talking this was years ago just out
of context years ago about six years ago
maybe five sixty five six years ago time
ago on went away odd talking ready to
start to [ __ ] start to lips there's
lights and lips lights [ __ ] Brava she
just sat on my dick started going go
when going I was like I was trying to
get her also because I asked was that
big like Mahad Oh every time you do this
it cracks me up this thing like I was
like get off so I'm gonna nut she said
no it scared me cousin I it night I
thought she was pregnant I don't see I
never saw her again because that was
just a one-time B and I knew and I think
she knew was gonna be one side but we
spoke for a bit afterwards I read said
and he died off did I tell you that
she's hauling me probably a year later
he told me I was at work I saw her name
pop up I Navy vomited
I nearly [ __ ] vomited bro scared the
[ __ ] out of me just a picture James R
saw it and immediately wanted the belly
minifigure out
I remember you text me I was at work or
something I remember specifically I was
thinking that would be the funniest
[ __ ] thing if she was pregnant the
funniest [ __ ] thing the one I always
talk about is that um that slip slip go
and exactly you mean yeah brother go
unrealistically wet vagina went to give
her the stinky pinky it slip straight
off I was like [ __ ] that's wet she
sounded and it was I don't know like I
felt okay because I'd already gone down
enough a time we were in a mad foreplay
but obviously dick games what counts
especially on the first impression from
I don't know what was going on me that
day no she's sad oh [ __ ]
she sat in and I've had two loads of
guys where they say like are when they
sit on it like cowgirls not but one mmm
for me it's the one as soon as she sits
on it um because I'm not in control I
told you before in it when I'm [ __ ]
if I'm in control and I'm the dominant
cat and I'm just all this yeah you can
control you could yeah brother like you
can you contain me and you just feel
more comfortable like I'm gonna [ __ ]
this [ __ ] up and I can't wait I'm just
gonna tear her up and it's gonna be sick
yeah and she's just gonna get dashed
around it's rough and tough and it's
gonna be amazing
yeah when they obviously try and play
the protagonist yeah
and they've in your hand on chest you
know them one oh yeah yeah yeah with one
leg over straddles down grabs you tall
you like
sound it Oh wet wet tight tight and I
was I [ __ ] you know and the thing is
well made it so much worse
mmm is that she was happy fam he was in
euphoria sani smiling eyes running back
everything and I was like she's having a
great time here brav little does she
know little does she know and I try I
knew I got the tingle tingles like early
three pumps in I knew by oh no no no and
I've tried to make a slowdown in it like
going for she was in a different world
euphoric gave it two more pumps and I
was like [ __ ] so in my head I'm like
right let me do something about this
yeah so I tried to like from the bottom
in it give it a like but from the bottom
just like maybe I can just blow her
brains out so in the head in the next
four seconds bro night and she didn't
even know that night oh she clearly was
in a different work she didn't hear me
or anything so she didn't know unless
she just fought that was like a standard
noise for me to make yeah and then like
she just kept going yeah and I was I
know and I was too embarrassed to tell
her like and then like she kept going
and she kept smiling yeah and then she
kept going and going and obviously was
getting soft til she clocked and I saw
the moment she clocked and her small
drop just looks at you yeah and did you
try to play it off like oh that was
great
I don't think we ever spoke again after
we went to sleep I left the next day
oh and I think we've spoken since but
just like because we have mutual friends
as though just in stories and we haven't
had a conversation yeah yeah but I was
that's one that like if I was single and
I was whatever and there were we were in
the same time in the same place I would
have to say redemption remark yeah round
two for sure with that Spanish upside
down question well
Redemption
that's illegal sound exotic fam oh it's
always about the first impression - no
matter which gotta [ __ ] whether your bun
buffer is one-night-stand Rhetta - I
have to give you that work I have to
whether or not I [ __ ] you again because
the be the banter of the girls group
chat can never be my portion boy
yes and the thing is you never know you
were never especially with someone you
know you're not prime not gonna see you
again same city it's like your bread
jeans are gonna know what my bit games
like so and this world is a is a full
circle you know I never know you're
gonna me again exactly just gonna be you
always known at that guy that I have a
bus is not early or she claims he's got
a small dick or do you know what I ran
so you've got to put that work yeah and
it works both ways as well because I've
spoken to I remember
my ex she was telling me years ago there
was a guy because there was a guy she
was living in Luton there was a guy that
I used to play basketball with or
against I can't remember
and then he lived down the road from her
or something mmm and he was our age and
I was like oh I think we saw him or
something like that and then Odessa she
obviously knew play basketball she was a
hard as a monk I know down the road he
plays basketball Tom his name is IRA I
played him before cetera cetera such a
cha-cha-cha and then she randomly said
she was I oh I was gonna [ __ ] him one
time and I was like why and then she was
like I don't know he was trying it with
me and my friend Tommy he had a big dick
and his like dick game was good and I
was like he was gonna get referral [ __ ]
Wow referral [ __ ] and I was like
congratulations that's what happens when
you put good dick down put the referral
[ __ ] that's just how the world works
with everything right good business you
get referrals
right word of mouth is everything right
and brav bad publicity listen does
terrible things to you terrible things
for you if a girl can go back and say
the dig in was tight you're gonna get
all kinds of all times because girls are
snakes and they will [ __ ] their friends
man anyway anyway so it's all good
everybody wins if your dick game [ __ ]
like his now I'm not now I'm getting
paranoid thinking about it obviously
there's not been that many occasions one
or two okay just every guy falls for it
yeah not [ __ ] because of those two
occasions yeah
that it was terrible and they went back
and said and limit our fortunes of the
day how was it imagine so much prefer a
policy out the window out the window
that's business out of the window we're
trying to run a business here burning
money out the window what we do be out
the window you've always got to put that
work in always regardless regardless of
who she is I know man regardless of
who's you that's ah it's mud it's mud
yeah man it's crazy
long story short I think from both of
our stories the moral of the story is
first impressions don't lay on top
that's clearly true by night we've
solved our own issues I'm tired first
time don't let it get on top unless
you've already been doing work for 15
min exactly yeah let's just finish this
part yeah yeah yeah this blows it down
don't never let us start on top because
that's a recipe for disaster especially
if the artists fart because for me I
love fit girls you know I love short
thick girls I know you do
so when I'm when I'm hitting that
squeezing I just just smacking it it's
just ah the euphoria sends me west rock
it says be West I can't help it I just
want a nut I don't care what a time
frame I don't care about huh what I care
about is me bro am i taller that's what
I care about
I know it's crazy [ __ ] crazy
ah obviously you've already established
once you've got some more dick that's it
that's it there's if you've got a small
dick there's nothing you can do about I
open to hear opinions from ladies that
would be like this guy got small dick
but he put like I don't even know what
they're gonna tell me if they've got
like a adverse opinion like nan and a
small dick works in this which way
they're knobs that's fine and I'm open
to hearing I don't know Mom I've been
hearing about it doesn't matter to me
but
yet and that's cool but and the general
consensus that I've heard is if your
stick is small is game over yeah and
there's nothing let's do it there's
literally nothing to do by it
you can eat [ __ ] to the cows come home
and that's fine for your girlfriend if
you've got a small dick and you've got a
girlfriend and she needs to be satisfied
and you just out here eating [ __ ] all
the time that's good for you guys fine
yeah you made it work your own way but
the first impression every do you have
much anxiety I would have every sing if
I dick was small how much anxiety I
would have every single time I got a
[ __ ] new girl every single [ __ ]
time I go to [ __ ] a new girl so I go
through this [ __ ] planet I'm
switching the light off
we can't [ __ ] broad daylight for sure
but even then you know once it goes oh I
know I know and if she when she grabs it
is how she grabs it did you ever like
this
ruff she give it she give it that [ __ ]
or she just this thing oh and then she
gives you actually suck she wore
finishes she goes she just fits the
whole teenager if you can fit the whole
thing in like first first first initial
and she's like oh and like I know his
bumps your abdomen because she wasn't
expecting to get the whole thing in her
gob and she's got balls in there he's
got a tongue on your taint she just goes
in then she's like wow is that it this
is what's about to [ __ ] me oh my god
could never be humiliating could never
be minute that's too much stress there's
that's anxiety right there that's I no
wonder people talk themselves as anxiety
but if you want a faithful man get a guy
with a small dick facts that's what just
just just just cleared up my head if
women are scared about getting cheated
on and you want a faithful man okay go
get a guy with a small especially if
you're good-looking go get a guy with a
[ __ ] small dick because he's it's
just not were not we're never gonna
cheat it's never good at TV it is not
worth the stress you've got too much to
lose you can't even Barriss yourself
with this new ting and you're gonna lose
you're gonna lose you go is it'll worth
it
I knew she's buff you'd be lucky to get
a new 100% good you're not going through
that again
oh god that's hilarious so yeah if
you've got a small dick or if you give
your go and you're worried about getting
you don't get gave us more drag out or
small with it man because it's just too
much stress
and I was not [ __ ] worth it Oh brav
what is that as three down no that's for
that was height hairline sex slash this
slash a dick game so we've got
financials there's pet peeve of mine you
talk about this every single day of our
lives
I'm not ashamed to say out broke we need
to be rich
I'm not shame sound broke this body
needs to pop as tired of living
month-to-month is also about like it
sounds stupid but then it doesn't sound
stupid this is like financial state
goose is like what is the definition
sometimes in our natural universe
obviously we have friends one who
example has probably got a [ __ ] half
a million in his banger and then you've
got other people like my brother for
example he's got like 10 grand in his
bank but he don't even earn that much
with money yeah so like is he in a
better [ __ ] he's obviously the best
final social situation than I am but
he's only in a better financial
situation than I am in a worst-case
scenario yeah like if his car poloz up
and he needs to bribe brand-new one he
can't afford to yeah exactly
but in a day to day life does that mean
his financial say this is bad not
necessarily so are you more talking
about the levels the tears the tears
yeah for sure so like you got like
mid-level team and yeah as an insecurity
for a guy too rough when I see guys with
money money yes if for example two days
ago we went out the VIP table cuting
that's Ana spitting example both like
table money and guests let's be on the
door money or two different is two
different tiers three different tiers
and one is full of guys and one is full
of three guys with 19,000 [ __ ] and
it's like think we're probably gonna
have a better time than them bro we're
gonna we're actually gonna fill up your
event so let me in let me in let me i'm
gonna buy drinks good party no at me if
they knew me they'd always let me in
because i buy drinks drinks i've spent
money I've spent table money on myself
because I'm an idiot
so let me in but I didn't want to buy at
a
no wants to spend that amount of money
in one go I'm gonna spend it in dribs
and drabs so let me in I don't want a
minimum spend and have all my drinks for
the night on the table takes away the
elusiveness and it makes me look like an
alcoholic the days that we have got
table I understood God that we've got
table yeah probably drunk less entire
lot less because one a lot of the reason
I buy drinks is to entertain my free
hand yeah when I'm talking about yeah
yeah like a Ben and walking around the
club with both hands very just like
you're clearly doing last day when you
got a drink in your hand it's cool you
do you're chilling
that's the lollipop game as well stop
stop you have a bloody nose on my
lollipop man I have a lollipop in a
shoobs it changes the game drink and
lolly mmm socializing best combination
to free hands you're walking around like
a [ __ ] 100% you're a predator you're
actually you're prettier you are you're
welcome our two free hands walking
around a club you're looking for someone
you're pretty you have a look at the
plate beef a man or look at the way look
at all rape which one is it everyone
neither of them as both the financial
stays this is like especially this
[ __ ] sea
it's just so humiliating is is mud and
it's like you could have a million like
I could have a million pounds of the
bank they would never know that but they
don't know that and if I'm not willing
to spend a table yeah look if I don't
know this flood like the club is going
into I didn't know if it's gonna be good
on [ __ ] yeah it's a opening night yeah
it could be [ __ ] dead yeah I don't
know so I don't want to drop a thousand
pounds yeah on a table in which it could
be [ __ ] because if it is [ __ ] there's no
getting 1,000 pounds back ya understand
but Dee's man that have spent a thousand
pounds on it they could have far less
money in the bank than I do
there Rick the rich rich and they're
getting laid yeah and we've got tables
before scary how much [ __ ] comes to the
table scary and I know they want to use
me for my [ __ ] drinks yeah and they
don't know who I am yeah and then I
might buy my car one day who knows yeah
yeah I don't know what the [ __ ] goes
through their head but initial instances
when they first come over you know
[ __ ] sky yeah yeah and then um once
the drinks are flowing stuff like that
you like this is what my fighters go
I came here it makes no sense it makes
no sense able at home come to mind like
what different Abel's I've got tables
and bowls from Ikea and freshers so
prices come to mind I'm to mine let's
ignore this and come to mind the same
situation one of them cost me 20 quid
the other one cost me at garand but
you'd [ __ ] me because I spent a grant oh
my god I could have read mortgaged my
house with this table we don't know that
I can I can find out what it is about
the perception of money not even factual
yeah show me your account your account
is the perception money weight is about
what is it about the perception of money
yeah that attracts ago yeah because I
can see a rich girl flashing I don't
give I don't flat I don't give a [ __ ] I
just care if you're good-looking on our
if you're buff and we talk and it's good
convo I want to smash you yeah I don't
give a [ __ ] if you drive a Lamborghini
if you drive a Ford Focus or a Kia or a
Fiat 500 I don't care are you pay for
not there's like a fax and if you can
make me laugh on top then you'll
probably get Mac married to me if I make
me laugh yeah bro came over don't care
what kind of financial situation you're
in like let's just saw sign out yeah the
perception of a guy having money it's a
different thing
hey just a mouse what he looks like as
well it drives them insane and I don't
know why bro it drives them literally
insane and do they think they're gonna
get a slice of the money because if it's
my money you're not you're definitely
not you're not definitely not I'm gonna
bang you and then I'm never gonna see
you again
Rex because I gave you the perception
I'm loaded this is why it doesn't make
any sense
at my gym in Miami mmm we're the VIP was
the club yeah if you ever go to Miami
man wasn't it imagine no imagine was the
better one mansion was where they had
three or four VIP areas that were big
around I mean the main yeah I know
anyways no way you're talking it was
like is that what you said a stripper
stripper the stripper the pole dancer
the [ __ ] yeah we defect it's a fear
the whole dance floor was the VIP happy
what it was crazy the whole dance floor
is the VIP obviously [ __ ] getting
free obviously man have to drop
thousands of pounds to get basically to
get in the club unless you want to sit
on a skirting board yeah you're not
getting in the climbing little drop a
couple thousand and The Blob weren't
even good the club of smaller [ __ ] is
the perception about the perception of
money is outrageous dream the dream
Corps dream dream dream dream dream
dream dream dream dream ruff
why oh why it just doesn't make sense to
me I need to know the answer it's gonna
rattle me on arm and it is is a game of
anxiety yeah we'll go out and it is an
insecurity sorry
in that we'll go out and if I look like
I got beat so when we were in the queue
the other day yeah as I said no one
knows how much money I've got in my bank
I could have it's 20 quid yeah I got 20
mil you know one knows all they know is
I haven't bought a table yeah that's the
facts that we have all the facts that we
have yeah is that I'm a standard looking
dude in the standard queue yeah on the
in the guest is cure whatever and I
haven't paid for a table that's all the
information that we have to work with
here agreed but I feel embarrassed I
feel pressure which is obviously their
plan yeah I feel pressure to get a table
cuz I'm like that's that I don't like a
schmuck yeah [ __ ] idiot yeah in this
brokedown Q this is the boss up queue
yeah and I want to be in the lavish q
yeah and it's like if I'm trying to if
I'm trying to move to a girl yeah I
can't do it in this queue that's not
seen my head yeah I'm not gonna get
anywhere in uski yeah look what's going
on because they're looking at you like
you're in the same queue as me you've
got no yeah why are you in this queue
why you don't talk to me if you're in
this kid get your table queue and then
we could converse why answer me why oh
my god is why is too funny it's [ __ ]
[ __ ]
oh Christ there's that remember that
time as well find that discipler for
financial status
thingy situation when I had a
was it the car before this one the car
before we went out for a family meal all
of us yeah my grill in the market yeah
yeah yeah yeah and then we're talking
about cars yeah and then someone's
girlfriend was talking about not letting
their boyfriend drive their car yeah
yeah and then they were like ah
why would I didn't drive my car I might
[ __ ] smash in they turned to me and
said James would you let him drive your
car and then before I had a chance to
answer was like wait you will cause
[ __ ] [ __ ]
let me not ask you and then they turned
to ya another one of our friends I was
like would you let me drive your car
your car's nice how dare you bro that
was years ago it's still in my head it
keeps me up at night how dare you
brother
and is embarrassing that when I upgraded
my car that was one of the first things
that come on man really [ __ ] this [ __ ]
let me draw it down there now I'll go
back for now I should have to live right
the basilar and that's not even my go
yeah that's one of my boys girls yes
there's not even my go or prospectively
someone that could be my girl yes one of
our boys girls yeah who's never gonna
have anything to do with me apart from
being a family member yeah and that's it
yeah I'm pretty and embarrassed about my
financial sales just someone to have
nothing to do with my dating life is
painful and so yes another one
yeah like financial say this is all
around girls
they have no reason she don't care about
my financial status because we're not
getting anything out of this persona
Saturday night of ball yeah maybe if it
was like a date situation yeah and it's
like I'm dating casually dating this
doesn't it could develop into something
yeah but not if we're meeting in the
[ __ ] queue of a club on a Saturday
night
come on that's hilarious what was the
last one
what was the [ __ ] last one so you've
got a hairline hi dick game financial
status
physique physique physique physique some
mad one because that one never goes away
mmm that one actually gets worse the
better your physique gets mm-hmm like
you're insecure about your physique it
gets you you rarely get to a point in
which you're like I want to make change
yeah I want to get big on my videos I
wanna get shredded whatever whatever
weather
and rarely do you get to a point in
black six months in a year in two years
in five years in me like perfect that's
the gone I'm gonna see what I had in my
head
found it it's done it never happens
never gets worse and worse no worse and
worse and worse almost I was this
publisher with bigger but I go free
staging the time growing like all right
Corman Potter films eyes eat some more
food again it'll be bigger and I'm like
bless just want to shut down you're
never concerned [ __ ] skinny you never
content never and that go you might as
well I was gonna say that doesn't even
just apply fit to males that flies
insanely yeah be Rose worse because
they're ready to go under the knife do
you know what I want yeah that's much
like a lot I get BBS like granted it at
times I think the big ass of it the
initial like oh my god you've got B B it
looks good until you actually keep
looking at ya like you know the one we
saw in the Cutie days ago the BB r we
saw in the queue oh yeah two days ago
obviously like when I say she cross the
road everyone was looking I liked
everyone guys and girls were just look
in her eyes cuz it was massive but after
that it's like I don't I would never
want to be your man because I don't want
that attention true I would never want
to be a man because I don't want man to
start looking at you like that like
you're a piece of me hmm
and I fight anyone for you you know what
you know what I actually it was actually
Jacob who posted this on his install a
logo is actually one of the most
insightful things I've ever read and
they actually changed my perspective on
a lot of things what do you know and it
was basically talking about how
obviously the changes women want to make
and if they want to get a boob job or if
they want to have to get that art on
whatever whatever whatever and it's like
a case of even if you look at someone
yeah and they say to you I want to get
my tits done yeah and so say if a girl
comes up to me and I want to get I wanna
get my tits done yeah and me saying to
them ah you don't need to get your tits
done you you look perfect how you are
something that means into them in my
mind is confirmation that they don't
need to change themselves or
confirmations they shouldn't do
something yeah because they look good
how they are but who the [ __ ] am I just
like you said about the
who are you to tell me I don't need my
haircut yeah Who am I to tell them that
they shouldn't do the changes to their
body yeah if they want to do because of
the perception that I have of them
because I because my taste
suits the way you look more now I'm
telling you not to do something in their
own life because I'd rather [ __ ] you the
way you look now rather than how you
would probably look if you got what you
want to come in so much sense and it's
like even though in my head I'm I'm
thinking I'm gonna being nice I she
doesn't change I'm actually not yeah I'm
actually being a [ __ ] and Jose might
be able I'm not doing it for you yeah
I'm doing it for me yeah and even if you
want to get the [ __ ] biggest ass in
the world and look you look stupid
yeah that's up to you yeah if it makes
us entirely up to you if you want to do
that that's entirely up to you and it's
not I'm Who am I to tell you who am I to
tell you yeah yeah you regardless if
like I think you look better one way
over I'm not you yeah I he doesn't
matter we also assume that go through it
because they think they'll get more dick
that way which they will obviously they
will fake tits and fake the last regular
all of that you're gonna get more dick a
lot more you good you're not necessarily
might get more dick you'll get a lot
more attention but you get more
attention gives you the option to choose
whether you get more dick that's true
you'll get way more attention to go you
showed me you show me a girl the other
day where she still kept the pictures
remember she still kept the pictures of
before she got it's done I can't
remember I know in stock I remember it
was a basically she had pictures
obviously fresh pics now and I remember
and she had pics of what she looks like
now and then she had pics of she still
retained the pics from before God you
save me a lot girls from before as well
and I was like that's brave usually they
delete all the ones on what they look
like previously yeah and they only keep
the ones this go disco disco so this guy
I don't remember the boobs done there
yeah and then she still kept yeah look
she still got the pictures oh snap
yeah I didn't scroll that far that's why
she's like an 11 pixpro
oh sure um but yeah she's obviously kept
those pictures yeah most guys will not
do that yeah
erase that for myself yeah they don't
want anyone to know that they never had
outrageously buffed it's mm-hmm that's
crazy
so yeah girls have it bad I don't know I
really don't know see the insecurity or
Falls both ways and I'm both sexes yeah
it's mud because because it's a trend as
well a lot of girls getting BB Elle's
recently a lot of girls have been
getting fake tits for like the past five
years and it's like if it's almost like
if you don't have it with like the teeth
thing veneers it's not it's almost like
if you don't have it you're not a part
of a certain social status yeah yeah
it's mad especially in the city
especially in the city fam for physical
augmentations I've never seen a scene
like this everyone's got something done
what everyone owns a business that's
doing something about physique or like a
parents or aesthetics or something it's
mud it's sorry matter like I told you
the other day I was at work I was doing
a private I was in a private room and it
was just tits and teeth everywhere
everywhere and it's like why and a lot
of them are older like they were like in
the forties maybe late 30s not me and
it's like why why don't have to do
obviously I'm assuming you're doing for
yourself but nine times out of ten
they're not doing it because they wanted
it they're probably doing it because
they're Brethren's done it they've seen
how they look they've seen the attention
they get they could be married did I
mean by it's just they look nice they're
getting attention convinced to do it
right I'm not adverse to being honest
and saying the reason I want to change
my physique the reason I always want to
look better is for me in essence yeah
it's more for me now because it's a
lifestyle thing now in the first
instance yeah [ __ ] right 100% [ __ ]
hundreds and I also didn't want to be
the guys again probably going back to
your original point about it being like
a main insecurity my worst fear has
always been like my girl either cheating
on me with a guy who has a better
physique than myself or breaking up with
me and Gamble someone who has a better
physique than myself and it's just like
the concept of upgrading is a is a
paranoia mmm and it's like also the case
of where
we said it before like a guy yeah if a
guy cheats like obviously guys cheat all
over the gaff yeah but if a guy cheats
like it's nothing
a lot of the time especially was just
sex which most of time it just is right
it's very rare that if a guy cheats that
he's done it because the girl is better
than his girl yeah or he's had even had
that in his head yeah his girl probably
didn't even pop into his mind yeah he
saw tits awesome whatever he just wants
the phone just wants to [ __ ] he probably
doesn't even remember her name
yeah he just wanted to bust a nut and it
didn't affect how he felt about his
girlfriend or any which way whatsoever
whereas a guy yeah like I said like a 40
like I can do that I even said like you
can have a girlfriend who has
unbelievable body yeah and then you and
and that's fine you love everything yeah
4d put exact same body yeah and you're
like I want I'm gonna smash I wanna
smash and you look exactly the same as
the person I'm [ __ ] but you're
different
yeah and a lot of time I think that's
just a male thing yeah and not even talk
about human males I'm talking about just
males in the animal kingdom from a
series like males in the animal kingdom
they will [ __ ] everything anything they
[ __ ] everything the lion femme you get a
line in the pride is always one guy bear
[ __ ] [ __ ] he's not he doesn't just
[ __ ] the banging was hilarious he
spreads as much seed as possible that's
a guy's job so a guy will [ __ ] goes that
uglier than his girlfriend reduces that
are less funny than his girlfriend have
shorter hair longer hair bigger tits
smaller tits bigger ass smaller ass fat
skinny he doesn't care so just its Joey
just [ __ ] was when girls be like ah look
at the guy look at the God that this
might guy would cheat on me we had blood
rising like for example we talking about
there was someone that he put on someone
online has some famous person economy it
was say oh you cheat ah Jesse lingard
Jesse Nygaard was with Jennifer Jennifer
emails and I pronounce the name and then
they showed the chick he cheated on her
with hmm obviously wasn't know
near as good-looking know what I mean
yeah yeah that doesn't matter does it
guys though even we'll never understand
that it doesn't matter
we just wanna bust that knot and if
she's making it easy to do so it's
better for her yeah just that come and
talk to me if your mass cheating on you
hmm with a girl that's uglier than you
yeah and he's taken her to Paris and
he's treating her like a queen and all
these things and he's not even [ __ ]
her yet
he's just treating her like his
girlfriend yeah yeah then talk to me
yeah because he needs help yeah I don't
know what the [ __ ] he's doing yeah he
needs a friend that's completely
different but if she's uglier than you
need just [ __ ] her it's because she
made it easy for me because she it was
easy accessibility doesn't care about
you any less he just needed to bust that
nut the thing about chiyan we've said
this before like when guys cheat guys
just cheat on impulse because they just
want a bus or not they don't care about
the girl they're not thinking about not
in a bad way but they're not thinking
about their girlfriend yeah it's just
stupid but it's in a good way yeah it
sounds stupid because cheating as a
whole obviously is stupid and you don't
I'm not know what this isn't a cheating
podcast listen this isn't a how-to you
on to cheat this is just facts this is
just this is the mountain atsumi's I'm
not great on Nikki we're not condoning
it we're just saying if and when a guy
cheats on whoever he's seeing it's
purely because he just wants the bus or
not and it's accessible for him to bus
or not and it's just easy but when
females cheat on guys it's a whole
nother ballgame purely because they're
either emotionally involved wrecks or
they tip or they just take it to another
level like they could be text in the man
all day every day
brav while I'm sitting there while I'm
in bed with while I'm in bed with you
like I would never do that I would not
do that cuz I don't care about this
other [ __ ] in the slightest navin that
much in the slightest I don't I just
hope you haven't got a number saved
she's a +44 I just went to the bus a +44
and that was it that was it whereas my
girl would have my man saved under an
alias to convince herself yeah Sara -
Sara
mobile and and they just are it's mud
FEMA's are worse than guys they come
with weeks you
once they get clocked eggs if you
confront denied to the bone and when you
finally clock them and they have no way
out well can you blame me
you never do this you never do that you
made me feel this way he looks after me
he looks after me the other day you said
I look fat I need someone who's gonna
make me feel good about myself you may
be [ __ ] about myself and all these
things no put on you it's just you're my
father ugh no thanks thanks for the vote
of confidence
yeah at least make me feel bad about the
fact that I've just put you chief now
I'm to blame bro you know guys don't
come with that [ __ ] we does some of them
probably do some of them are [ __ ]
but they're lying facts rough goals are
lying and they come with the utmost [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] and
it's just like I've shut up admit it you
want the dick you got the dick and he's
loved how you kept going yeah and they
will also do it with someone who looks
better than you in their opinion mmm
they will also do it it's more out of
spite yeah and in their mind is an
upgrade yeah in their head like cuz
that's another thing as well there's
another thing about obviously like I
said about the animal kingdom for males
yeah Anna looking them for females yeah
is like biologically you want to [ __ ]
them as alpha yeah for the best see if
you guys all waste yeah if you're no
offense but if you guys small if he is
more of an intellectual than an athletic
guy and he might have a great
personality and he might actually be
kind of financially stable and stuff
like that but then you've got another
guy he's a [ __ ] ex MMA fighter he's
tall as [ __ ] he's jacked yeah um he's an
alpha guy he'll throw you around know
what that case in point no buff buff
chick is gonna go out go out and say oh
I'm [ __ ] a dentist a dentist and it's
about half a mil a year but if I'm
[ __ ] [ __ ] one Donnie from if she's
[ __ ] one Bonnie formula like Watford
for so what for a football club he earns
what 10k a month they're gonna bang him
they're gonna bang him because he's on
TV
Frank's brags they won't [ __ ] a dentist
someone asked why his head screwed on
that one can give you our life and
probably would never cheat on you
bird are you gonna [ __ ] a footballer
this is the animal King just because
you want that AlphaDog yeah yeah you
think he's an alpha that's it and that's
it and bro cheating is everyone [ __ ]
cheats for one monogamy isn't real - man
monogamy is made up again I'm not
condoning I'm not but yeah and like he's
crazy that like women need to understand
that it's not about them when they click
there that I think that's the main
bottom line of it yeah is that once
you've been clocked cheating they need
to understand it's nothing to do with
them there's nothing so if they're
looking at the girl yeah you're wasting
your [ __ ] time you probably know what
she looks like more than he was yeah
because we probably know much more about
the girl than he does yeah he doesn't
care doesn't care about her he probably
hasn't thought I by her since he just
wanted that knot in there and it was
done it was done with he didn't care
there's just literally that it was
probably the same as wanking to him Yeah
right same and his price crazy hilarious
right absolutely crazy and I was
listening to another podcast a little
while ago and actually broach this topic
perfectly and it's like more about what
it was asking people and males and
females what they found what they're
like
what would infuriate them more what
their biggest fear is more from their
partner to do and it's like for they
asked them the same questions like would
you be more upset if your if they asked
of guy would you be more upset if your
partner was having a sexual relationship
with someone else yeah
and nothing else they didn't speak to
him they didn't do anything that was
[ __ ] them yeah would that upset you
more than if they weren't [ __ ] them
but they had a really strong emotional
and the guys were always more vex if she
[ __ ] him mmm the guy they didn't give
a [ __ ] if if if they had an emotional
attachment to someone and they were
really good friends with someone and
they spend a lot of time the guys didn't
give a [ __ ] mmm he said I'm being much
more pissed off if my girlfriend [ __ ]
another guy then if she had a close
friend who wasn't guys after that
doesn't bother me the women all said
they'll be more upset not all sad
obviously but there's more significant
that the women would say there would be
more paranoid and more upset if a man
had an emotional attachment yeah yeah
because they see it as
as a threat yeah they see it as more as
a threat so a guy sees his main purpose
as [ __ ] being like a protector being
an alpha being all these things that are
physically dominant yeah and it would be
more paranoia for them to want for them
to want to [ __ ] someone else yeah more
than they want to [ __ ] them yeah because
it means that their debates are in the
next man's that alpha whereas women
they're more based on being providers
nurturers emotional stability and all
these things so if you're getting your
emotional needs from another [ __ ] yeah
what a good a day what good that here's
facts I heard up so bright that's just
how it works man that's just how it
works so yeah women if you are if you
get cheated on don't bother looking at
the girl cuz it's nothing to do with it
literally doesn't [ __ ] matter and if
guys they're getting cheated on and boy
he if he's big you probably should look
at the guy because he's bigger than you
hit the gym BAM you're the bait I'm he's
the Alpha yeah because I've you know
Dave I don't see how cheated on bro
females always want the top dog
regardless of what they say to you even
if like what what annoys me the most is
that it doesn't annoy me it's just it's
just a thought so a lot of the times you
see like we were talking about this
earlier why we see a lot of buff girls
with average looking guys nine times out
of ten he secured this girl five years
ago before she was anyone before she
even a made changes to a physique if she
did be before she got famous or becoming
celebrity or whatever for example but
because of the love she has for him
she's gonna stay with him because she
knows him and he knows her mmm right
regardless of how many times she's been
moved to regardless she's always gonna
be that faithful person she's gonna
cheat though she she come to me she gone
cheat whether it be sexually emotionally
sure she's going to cheat because
there's only a finite amount of times
you can get moved him and say no that's
fact had this conversation actually with
Jay and Aaron know while ago when I was
in London I actually had this specific
conversation they were like did you talk
about cheating as well and they're
talking about like guys that she and
guys that don't cheat I'm basically
saying there aren't guys that don't
cheat and it's like if that you've got a
guy if you've got a guy that hasn't
it's because he couldn't and it's true
in the world it's more you know it's
more of the case of accessibility
accessibility someone it's harder for
someone to stay faithful when you've got
300 [ __ ] trying to [ __ ] him every day
then Harold in marketing mmm or
accounting wherever who is ugly as [ __ ]
yeah
and never gets moved to gets moved to
you once a year yeah it's easier for
Harold to say no that one time a year of
course it is for [ __ ] Tyrone to say
no day yeah is that's just facts and
then like it's no surprise that
celebrities get caught out cheating more
often than not yeah because they've got
unrelenting amounts of [ __ ] thrown at
them all the [ __ ] time every single
minute of every single any single minute
of every single day someone's trying to
[ __ ] them it's a lot harder to say no
every single [ __ ] time
you're gonna give in eventually you're
gonna give in lucky for me I'm ugly and
no one ever wants to message me no one
ever must have meant to me so I'm
faithful this [ __ ] easy for me because
I'm ugly brother no one wants to move to
me I'm how old from accounting so that's
hilarious
I'm literally calm I'm not I don't she
I'm single anyway so it's fine but um
yeah bro it's like you're right there's
only so many time she's gonna say no and
when she's with a guy like we said if
she's with a ugly guy wherever on his
small guy whoever and big Donnie who's
[ __ ] handsome moves to her and
doesn't take no for an answer on round
one mmm she's going to [ __ ] him because
eventually it'll break down because I
was I can't remember he was talking
about who his from but it was an example
man said there's a buff girl in the
office and is about four or five guys in
the office
mm-hmm regardless of whatever you think
you're doing at work work has not become
a playground for who's gonna [ __ ] her
first
if you all think she's buff and she
knows that you know we all think you're
buff hmm every guy's gonna mold themself
into the person she believes is the best
person to [ __ ] her
so eventually she's gonna say yes to
someone whether she's got a man or not
let's say she's got a man God knows
where
especially if he lives up
it's long it's long don't have a man
that lives abroad it's long it's long
you just accept the fact that you again
she it again hiding in a toilet it's
long it's long so long because man down
will make it gestures just to get the
[ __ ] men do crazy things just for sex
bro it's why they actually do this white
like we said like we said babe at the
beginning let's podcast like hard dick
makes it's just it's that endless cycle
and the cycle of [ __ ] it's like the
last one when I was high twenty minutes
and I didn't know where I was just
because I wanted to bus or not right
it's crazy it's crazy when we was
talking about the crazy ting bash bash
back a day and I came around the yard
and everything was broken all the gifts
I bought all were broken there are new
reason she had all those gifts boost cuz
I wanted to bust that nut she had so
many gifts to break because I didn't
[ __ ] afraid all the gifts that she could
bro
uh women are crazy bro yeah [ __ ] nuts
they're crazy I know something I was
literally gonna say about what you were
just talking about hilarious I can't
remember what it was but yeah men let's
you more themselves into whoever we want
to be to impress you and that's facts
that's like fact apply forces facts it's
[ __ ] facts for the girls as well and
girls love to play like they're cool
their man in it they love to call her
they're the cool guy yeah they love
watching anime they love playing games
they love they're sick they're sick at
FIFA apparently every girl sick of
people I planted a horipad oh she loves
card apparently and I'm not the fish Rob
she loves all the [ __ ] that you love and
you're like rah gang this girls sick
until push comes to shove she actually
doesn't like anybody dead she's dead a
fever
yeah she's [ __ ] trunk oh I didn't
want to [ __ ] this girl but I was at the
gym one time doing some cardio and one
girl that works there asked me if
because I let play squash in it
azam suppression apes' question also I'm
saying I would favor and she was oh I'm
really good at squatching I was that
really she was like yeah like my cheek
if this whole spiel about she's actually
dead legally xanga [ __ ] and she's a very
nice girl but boy oh god awfulness for
any god wasted an hour of my time oh god
I hate that and I'm too nice a guy to
blame yeah yeah wait you said you were
good this [ __ ] yeah I gave up cardio to
do this cardio
yeah and he's terrible yeah and it was
why I was there was on top of the
context I wasn't running [ __ ] she
wasn't running [ __ ] me
she was seen one of my boys anyway hmm
so it was just a waste I she wasted
everyone's time to play this stupid game
of squash I don't know I like don't lie
to me yeah because I take my squash
[ __ ] seriously that's if you're gonna
come in a ring tell me you good as
working baby if I can get as well yeah
yeah but anyway but yeah it's just like
anyone will mold I told to be the person
that they need to be present any think
you want them to be yeah bro there was a
girl that I was trying to court as you
work up a few years ago and it was a TV
was WB to remember WB mmm-hmm and this
person was like we had so little in
common and she was so [ __ ] rough and
she was like way into fitness which
obviously I am we have that in common
but she was more like a crossfit style
like classes and anything that gets your
heart rate going yeah she was into it
and that wasn't me yeah but yeah
extremely into fitness was like a vegan
all this [ __ ] broth in the time that I
was trying to [ __ ] this girl the amount
of vegetables I ate the amount of times
I met her at the gym at 6 o'clock in the
morning to train you never told me that
I didn't want to study this murder is
not a mistake
I didn't tell you that I was getting up
a dick at o'clock before the Sun came to
train with this guy at the gym
bro stupid did I [ __ ]
no no of course I did I know you know
you don't [ __ ] I know I didn't [ __ ]
she [ __ ] left the country I know
nothing ever happened
Rob just because I fought I need to be
this guy and another thing that hard
dick makes you do is convince yourself
that it's not just about the [ __ ]
because if I knew it was just about
[ __ ] this girl I would have quit yeah
you know I'm saying yeah I wouldn't have
done that cuz I would have been like oh
wait James is just a [ __ ] yeah you're
not getting up at [ __ ] 5 o'clock in
the morning for [ __ ] you wouldn't do
that when you know it's just [ __ ] like
if someone said it's gonna [ __ ] me you
black oh no help it why are you awake
can you yeah you were [ __ ] even if
they said wake up yeah
wake up and talk to me on the phone at 5
o'clock in the morning yeah three days a
week for the next month and at the end
of it 50/50 flip a coin on my [ __ ] you
you'd be like your [ __ ] I'm not
doing nothing but in your head it's not
just about you actually secretly wanna
turn vegan you want to Train early in
the morning you notice for your best
interest actually it's a great way to
start the day all these things are very
ahead because in your head it's not just
about the person yeah it's about like
it's the game myself I didn't know and
then when you never got that [ __ ] and
it all dwindles away I [ __ ] you like the
clarity is just about the person I never
got a [ __ ] on whether fado just wasted
wasted my [ __ ] time wasted my time
it's nuts
Wow me not yeah we should wrap this one
up this is a long one it's a very long
one you going on for like I didn't even
know so you can see the time when we
started but long hour a bit long story
short post not clarity is key post not
clarity the terms are I like you or not
the five fingers of death ako five mils
insecurities nuts yeah yes